foreign
we're going to uh hey good afternoon
Victor hey Daniel hi Alex hey Ben
Hillary hey Carlo where are you guys
coming from
Martin
um
Chile
even Chile Boston Germany oh my God it's
going so fast Oxford Italy to Barcelona
hey Kurdistan Pittsburgh India Colombia
Brazil Kosovo Atlanta New York City oh
my God it is so much fun
Calgary
Toronto hey Italy
hi Austin hey Madrid hi Germany hi
Amsterdam hey Beijing Australia
Indonesia Ecuador oh my God are you guys
sleeping you should be sleeping right
now Munich
Brussels oh from Mars all right nice
very International
thanks everybody for joining we're gonna
let uh another minute for our people to
settle in
hey Alex
hey Jerusalem
all right this is uh so much fun we've
been uh we've been waiting for for this
moment uh for for quite some time
working up to it
um super excited to uh show you uh our
new uh infants
solution
yay thanks Alex
it's finally here it is finally here
it's actually already here it's here
we're just telling you about it now but
uh we're pushing the race button at the
same time
yes
this will be big for front end I think
this will be big for uh for everybody
because what we're doing is we're
accelerating the adoption of machine
learning models
right so that means that's as a data
scientist I can go all the way
as a machine learning engineer I can go
all the way as a software developer I
can pick a model and go all the way
so
super excited yeah
all right
um maybe
maybe we should get started what do you
think Phillip
sounds good all right I'll maximize
myself
uh and uh and uh and get started so
today we are introducing
a new Solution on the Hub to take your
models and take them to production and
that's called hugging face inference
endpoints
it's live today you can try it out today
and I will tell you uh how it works
and then Philip will show you how it
works in a demo and we'll leave 10
minutes at the end uh for questions I'm
Jeff Woody I'm on the product team at
hugging face Philip is our Tech lead and
we're super excited to show a hiding
face inference endpoints to you today
and uh let's get right into it so what
is this what is hiking face inference
endpoints well it's a solution for you
to easily deploy your models on
dedicated and fully managed
infrastructure it's a solution for you
to keep your costs low
with security and a ton of flexibility
so what does that mean what that means
is that we made your models Plug and
Play what I mean by that is that any
model you can take and plug it into your
app or service using hiking face
inference endpoints
all right so why did we go about
creating this thing
um one thing that came a lot in hundreds
of conversations with users of companies
of any size is that a lot of the machine
learning projects coming out of data
science do not make it make it into
production do not get integrated into an
app or service
and there is a this stat I plugged from
Venture a bit that says that 87 of data
science projects never make it into
production and that's data science in
general for the largest models for
Transformers for diffusers that stat is
probably uh underestimated and the
reason why what came up through all
those conversations is that the process
for a model to make it all the way into
an app that people can use is pretty
complicated pretty convoluted uses a lot
of software and it's a very lossy
process from the data scientist they
will take a user notebook to create and
fine-tune a model and get a checkpoint
for that checkpoint to get into a
container they will then deploy it into
infrastructure so that developers can
pick up an API and build a feature that
whole process usually takes months two
to three months before a model can make
it into the hands of the end user of the
customer and that's a reason why AI
there is such a lossy process in putting
models into production and if you're
trying to do everything that I describe
yourself
then you're entering into a world of
pain where all of a sudden you have to
deal with gpus and dependencies and how
do I put this into a container image and
how do I deploy this using kubernetes
this is a whole new world A Whole New
World of pain but with uh getting face
inference endpoints uh pain no more the
pain goes away you can use hugging face
and points on the Hub you can model and
gets right get your API or endpoint
all right but how does it work it works
in three simple steps uh the first one
is to pick your model any model that is
hosted on a hiking face Hub can be
deployed into an endpoint there are over
70 000 pre-trained checkpoints available
today from Transformers and 25 other
libraries you can pick any of those and
of course you can pick your own models
that you have fine tune uh and that you
are hosting on the hugging face Hub once
you get your model the next step is to
select your Cloud today at launch we
have AWS and Azure available and then
pick your region the region you want to
pick so that's your model lives as close
to your data as possible to reduce
Network overhead
so that's it three simple steps and what
you get what you get is a production
solution that keeps your cost super low
it was super important for us to build
something that you can use and getting
the benefits of like if you were to do
it all yourself uh from scratch
um but without the pain and to get
predictability on your cost you pay as
you go for what you use uh the costs
that we have start at six cents per hour
for a CPU core instance and 60 cents per
hour for a GPU instance so put in a
credit card and you're ready to go
all right so if you cut slow you pay as
you go but then one of the best things
about inference endpoints is that you
can bring in any model and you custom
and you can customize your inference
pipeline your way so by default we built
integration uh with uh all the tasks
from the Transformers library and the
sentence Transformers Library so you can
bring a model and it will work out of
the box leveraging uh the pipelines but
then what if you want to customize the
inputs that goes into your model what if
you want to customize what comes out of
your model Custom pre-processing Custom
post processing well you can do that
very easily with a single
python file a single Handler that py to
define a custom pipeline for your model
but what if you don't want to use a
Transformer or sentence Transformer
model what do you want what if you want
to use a diffuser model what if you want
to use Optimum to use the accelerated
inference pipelines well then you can do
so also super easily with the same
handler.py file for custom inference
pipeline and if you want to go all the
way custom you can also bring your own
custom container image so a fully
flexible solution for your production
needs
okay and to talk about this I want to
let Andrea do the talking Andrea he's a
data scientist at music's match uh they
are the world leading music data company
and with hiking face endpoints they were
able to deploy super easily super quick
uh fully custom uh inference pipeline to
generate custom embeddings from lyrics
so here's what Andrea had to say about
it
the coolest thing was how easy it was to
define a complete custom interface from
the model to the inference process it
just took us a couple of hours to adapt
our code and have a functioning and
totally custom endpoint so we started
from like two to three months to take a
model to production and now we have a
couple of hours
okay but what if you want to customize
uh what goes uh under the hood well you
can do so by going into the advanced
configuration menu and select the exact
accelerator that you want to use for
your model you have various choices of
CPU accelerators leveraging Intel
isolate of GPU accelerators and you can
select the right size for your model
and for auto scaling it's as easy as
setting the minimum and the maximum
numbers of replicas so that your
endpoint will scale up and down as the
number of requests evolves so super easy
Auto scaling super easy way to sit set
up the exact infrastructure that you
need
and then once your model is up as an
endpoint the ml apps part of it becomes
completely integrated and easy you get
logs you get monitoring you can
customize your analytics routes you can
create update delete and manage all of
your endpoints programmatically
and you can easily go from one model
revision to the next using the hiding
face hot versions
all right so to talk about uh this
um I want to uh refer Gareth who's a
product manager at Pinecone pinecone.io
is a smart Vector database for
intelligent search and the first thing
that customers need to do to use
leverage Pinecone for inclusion search
is to create embeddings so here's where
what Gareth had to say we're able to
chew an off-the-shelf model that's very
common for our customers to get started
with and set it so that it can be
configured to handle over 100 requests
per second with just a few button clicks
so that's automated Auto scaling with
hagging face inference endpoints
but then what about security so with
security in inference endpoints you get
three different security levels for each
endpoint so here pictured in green the
public setting so that your endpoint is
available from the internet with
encrypted uh communication connection
the protected mode here picture in
purple allows you to only accept
requests authenticated with a hiking
face token and then the most secureable
the private setting leverages under the
hood AWS private link or Azure private
link to establish a direct connection
between your VPC and the hiking phase
endpoints in the same region of the same
Cloud so that when running inference
there is never any data that lives on
the internet so with the private
endpoints you have a ready-to-go
solution that is compliant with
financial services use cases Healthcare
use cases all the regulated use cases
and to talk about this I want to bring
to the stage uh to fix and Bryce
configures and CTO and co-founder at
family they built a healthcare
experiences that reduce the
hospitalizations through machine
learning
hi I'm Topeka I'm the co-founder and CTO
family from John health
and I'm Bryce I'm a senior software
engineer at family
and family is a smart care manager
platform that helps medical groups
Health Systems deliver proactive care
for high-risk patients between their
office visits and when you do that
through simple conversational messaging
so let's say you've got elderly parents
grandparents Aunts Uncles with chronic
conditions like diabetes hypertension
heart conditions Etc they might see
their doctor two to three times a year
and with family they'll talk to their
doctor's office two to three times a
month and address any issues before they
become really costly complications or
complex issues and so doing that we've
built probably the largest
conversational data between patients and
clinicians and we're building out really
an early detection early intervention
system at population Health scale so as
you can imagine that involves a lot of
machine learning
foreign
containing millions of healthcare
conversations family uses Transformer
models to improve the quality of care
that patients receive simple example is
when a patient messages their doctor
using the family the first thing to read
what they wrote is a Transformer based
classification
that model triages the messages urgency
and our application routes
within the first month of that model's
launch it played a part in running
numerous hospitalizations
and that's really only the tip of the
iceberg for what we've done and what we
plan to do at transform uh that's why we
need a solution for deploying
and wonderfully efficiently
so before inference endpoints we
deployed our models using an in-house
architecture built on AWS Lambda and API
Gateway and we're we're a growing
startup with a lot of work and limited
bandwidth so it means that anytime
you've been creating and maintaining
this architecture prevented us from
working on other initiatives
between authentication and versioning
monitoring the maintenance costs of
building it ourselves really added up
over time uh without inference endpoints
we would have spent a lot more time on
on those non-core activities and we
would have eventually needed to expand
our infrastructure team to keep up with
all the models that we were working on
uh my favorite thing has been just how
easy it is to start using you know
within a few hours literally reading the
docs for the first time we were able to
get a model deployed and it took almost
no new code
um deploying that same model with AWS
using our old architecture took uh often
a week's worth of developer time so
having it done almost no time was game
changing disabilities uh yeah and
in addition to that being able to deploy
so seamlessly that's more of our uh more
members of our team developed deploy and
test models without bothering someone
from
thanks to inference endpoints we now
basically spend all of our time on R D
not fiddling with data
that's huge so working in healthcare
data security is Paramount you've got
HIPAA and you've got to be able to
really ensure that your data stays
secure so our clients and their patients
they entrust us with very personal
protective health information and we are
legally and morally obligated to secure
data and data breaches and HIPAA
violations are existentialists for a
company that's the thing that keeps you
up at night as and so being able to
deploy endpoints using private link
talking face provides that peace of mind
uh that both the pichai laden data is
not susceptible to men in the middle
attacks or and that our endpoints will
never be accessible by any anyone other
than our application and that uh
definitely helps usually way easier at
night
I think pretty much anyone uh using
Transformer models could benefit from
using inference endpoints uh if you
haven't already built a robust
performance fault tolerance system for
inference then it's pretty much a
no-brainer and even if you have built a
system like that I bet that you spend
more money maintaining it than you would
using
thank you so much and react Gareth to
feed Bryce for bringing your your your
testimony your experience of hiking face
inference endpoints uh to to us today
there are more uh customer success
stories available if you go to
huggingface.com inference endpoints you
can learn more about music's matches
experience about
families experience about pine cones
experience and about waymark's
experience so check it out but first let
me recap a little bit everything that we
covered so today with hiking face
inference endpoints you have a solution
to easily deploy your models
um in a solution that keeps your costs
down where you pay as you go you have
predictable pricing
um as your application scales a solution
that gives you all of the ml Ops uh
benefits in just a single a few clicks
sorry you can select your instance type
you can set your auto scaling and you're
ready to go
it's a solution that is fully flexible
if you have custom pre-processing custom
post processing whichever type of
machine learning model you want to
deploy you can do so easily with
inference endpoints and it's a solution
that gives you security all the way to
direct VPC connection with private
endpoints so that your thing that never
leaves on the internet and so okay
that's enough talking about it now I
want to let Philip show you uh how it
works how you can use uh inference and
today
right from the Hub and deploy your
models in a few clicks so with this I'll
let you take it over Philip
foreign
so hey and what we are going to do in
the demo now is we will deploy one model
and and then like show all of the the
features Jeff mentioned
um during his presentation this includes
blocks metrics we can also take a quick
look and because somebody asked them how
our custom handle looks for like an
optimized model and then we can answer
some questions so what you can see on
the screen is currently like the the
creation view of the UI so endpoints
will be available through a UI and which
you can access on
ui.npoints.hagingface.co and it has also
like everything you do is
programmatically accessible meaning you
can integrate it into your CI pipelines
and everything we will do in the UI can
be done programmatically and in the
documentation there is basically a whole
Swagger UI with all of the available
rods where you can take a look on what
you can do programmatically okay so so
the first step basically since every
endpoint is connected to a high interest
repository is to select our repository
which includes our model or models so
you can for example have like multiple
models and one repository and then work
with a custom handle to like load both
of them what we are going to do in the
example since Transformers are not only
limited to text anymore we will use uh
an image model we will use the bitmodel
from Google for image classification we
have like a search integrated so if you
are not finding your repository you
might need to check it again for
permission and then each endpoint has
the name we will go with image
classification and then the next step
would be to select the cloud we will
stay with AWS but since I am in Germany
this means I will go with the Europe
region and then I would be ready to
deploy my endpoint
um that's something we are going to do
and in addition
um so if you want to change the instance
type or the auto scaling you can click
on Advanced configuration and then
select your instance type maybe we
should update it to a bigger CPU
instance for now and the replica are
okay and we want to to be protected so
only my organizations and people who are
in my hiking first organization can use
the endpoint
and now what's going to happen on the
backhand side is basically we are
creating unique image artifacts which
include the model weights and the
inference serving container and and are
then decoupled from
the
credit chap is playing around with the
screen are then decoupled from the
hanging face Hub so each endpoint is
uniquely to a specific State and the
revision this means that you can like
update the revision or in case something
is like not available on the hanging
face side your endpoint stays up and
running and
um each endpoint has also a unique UI
which we will see in a minute and we can
then also run inference as you know from
the model cards as well as update our
endpoint but while the container is
building we can take another look at an
already deployed endpoint which is the
distal Bird model which was optimized
with Optimum it is basically a simple
Dynamic quantization and then some graph
operation you have few fused operators
for the CPU I'm going to use and that's
the view you have when you have a deploy
endpoint you will have our your your
unique UI and you have the inference
widget and then you you can immediately
try your endpoint maybe we should use
the prompt which makes a bit more sense
so I was on the Oktoberfest on the
weekend but
on a bad case I lost my credit card and
the model was fine-tuned on the banking
77 data set and when we scroll down a
bit we should see okay that's correctly
labeled with lost or stolen card so
that's something which works and also
you can see there are like the examples
available which you might know from The
Hiding face app and then as we mentioned
we have blocks and analytics or metrics
available so logs you have your locks to
your running container here we can see
all of the requests so while Jeff was
presenting the slides I con content you
continuously ran some requests and here
we can see the request time for our
models inside use a pretty small prompt
the latency is super low but we can also
look down a bit to have more requests
and also we can see I guess through my
request my model scaled up and I also
started the second part in addition to
this we also have logs available for the
building part meaning if during your
creation of your endpoint for whatever
reason you try to deploy a model where
you don't have access or something else
didn't work out you have logs available
to like all of like the creation of your
endpoint and here you can see that we
downloaded the model from the hanging
face app
okay and then what do we have available
for Analytics
um wait this should bring up some nice
metrics
except all of you went to yeah you know
um currently we have the replica our
account available we have the total
number of requests and then we have an
average and the P95 latency something to
mention for the average in P95 latency
it is calculated over the whole last 30
minutes and then divided or took the
percentile or of it which means as you
can see here beginning of of eight when
I deployed at 18 or 6 PM when I deployed
the endpoint it was a super high P95
latency since the first request takes
some time to like validate your token
and allocate all of the resources but
when you as you can see when I had like
my continuous like request load going on
it was super low and then also you can
see basically the load for over the
duration when I send a request here you
will also see
500 requests or five five or one for
example if someone which is not
authorized to your endpoint tries to
send request
okay we can go back to our image
classification okay the load balancer is
not ready which should take maybe 30
seconds or something more and then the
end point is ready normally the the
endpoint creation takes three to five
minutes it really depends on if it's the
first endpoint into your account which
might take a bit longer since we are
creating some DNS records and like
creating the first dot balancer
um which takes some times but then
normally the creation really depends on
how big your model is if your model is
bigger then of course creating the image
and I've been downloading the model
takes a bit longer maybe you can answer
one or two questions while we wait for
the request or for the end point to be
up
I've been trying to keep up with uh with
all the questions lots of great
questions uh here
um
how does the auto scale works
um it works by looking at the
utilization
um of the current infrastructure for
your endpoint so as you get more
utilization uh the uh endpoint will will
scale up with the number of replicas of
of the container is it possible to
integrate the system with kubernetes
well the whole point of inference
endpoints that you don't have to fiddle
with deploying and scaling
infrastructure with kubernetes so all
that is abstracted
um any idea how to charge money per
inference with the hosted model uh
that's uh that's a good question here
we're really uh taking that uh model
um upside down and we're providing an
easy to use low-cost uh production
infrastructure solution
um how you monetize your service with
your end users and customers is really
up to you
um what is the default image that's
being run to service the models is it a
flask server nvx writing server
um so inference endpoints will create an
optimized image depending on what type
of model you've selected depending on
what type of instance you've selected
and will sort of automatically create
the the optimized image container for
that
um using a built-in Transformer
pipelines and integrating with your
customization via thehandler.py file
yeah but maybe to add so it's like we
provide like this defaults software
serving container working with the
Transformers tag tasks and the custom
Handler but it doesn't mean that you
cannot use like TF serving for example
or Trident if you want to use tried and
that's what we enable through like the
custom container where you could then
like provide either like a Public Image
or a private image from your ECR or is
CR registry basically and since Jeff
answered some questions my endpoint got
ready and now as you can see since we
have an image endpoint
I also have the nice image
um
widget which you might know from The
Hiding face up and I um use the test
image which is a hiking face merge and
my
endpoint correctly classified it as
Jersey t-shirts
um yeah prospects maybe they are like
Stone prospects or mailbox and also a
backpack might be there I'm not really
sure but our model works and also
something nice to mention so we can like
also take a look at the Json output so
in case you are not sure about the API
structure or you want to make sure okay
what's what what's getting the what's
the response or if your application team
or front-end team needs to know okay
what is basically the body I'm expecting
as a response they can like open the UI
basically and check the run and
inference and check the request and also
there's the copy SQL button which
creates a curl statement from the exact
request we run but I'm not going to show
it since we're it will include our token
we need to send request and maybe then
and since we have a few more minutes
left before we go to the questions so I
can show how a custom Handler looks and
we have several already pre-created
endpoints template available on the
hiking face Hub those are available
through the endpoints template tag we
have one for OCR we have sentence
embedding we have one for clip we also
have a stable diffusion demo we have and
then of course our digital bird Onyx
model and in there
um all requirements for creating a
custom Handler is an handler.py file and
which is uh yeah a symbol a simple
python class with an endpoint Handler
and this endpoint Handler needs to have
two method which is the init method and
the call method the init method will be
called on endpoint creation and we will
it will receive one argument which is
the path to where all other repository
artifacts are stored so basically we get
a path where all of our files from our
repository are stored which include our
model files and configuration files and
for our
accelerated model that we are using the
ort model class from the optimum Library
loading our tokenizer and then creating
our pipeline using our RT model and then
for a call we receive a Json input with
inputs as key and also parameters in
case we want to customize it and then we
are running inference and returning back
the dictionary which will then be
converted into a Json again and also
since we are using Optimum which is not
pre-installed into our container we are
adding a requirement txt with the
optimum version and in this case the
Onyx runtime and sub package for it
meaning that you can also install
custom python packages into your
endpoint
thank you okay
and that that's mostly it for the demo
um I think I'm not sure if we have
shared all links yet so you can get
started by going to hiking phase and
ui.npoints.com and if you are not having
uh yeah a plan set up you will see some
nice small little prompt explaining
basically the next steps you need to
take to to get started and then also
um we have documentation available
um which includes basically everything
we have shown it includes all of the
security Concepts you have uh like the
supporter tasks including the expected
request payload you have the API
references with the integrated Swagger
UI so you can like okay get a better
feeling of how the the backend API works
and then we have several guides for okay
how can I access the UI or the solution
how can I create my first endpoint and
also a very detailed examples on how can
I create a custom Handler for example
the Open Eye Has released the whisper
model last week I guess every one of us
have seen or heard about it on social
media we already have created uh
in an example for it on how you can
deploy it
true whenever
it's not opening
okay maybe the link is wrong but it's
there I can share it which basically is
really again custom python class and
then we have our whisper package which
is currently installed from the open AI
repository and then you can like try it
on if you are interested in it it's it's
super simple to get started
okay
okay
that's it
thank you so much Philip that was super
cool we saw how you were able to create
from scratch a new endpoint in just a
few minutes uh see the latency of each
request how you get the whole uh logs
about uh the whole history so you have a
good sense of the volume you're hitting
uh the performance of the solution uh
how the auto scaling Works uh so really
really cool
um there were so many questions I tried
to answer as many as I could uh while
you were doing the demo uh plenty I
didn't get to perhaps we can take five
to ten minutes
um and uh and try to
uh to to answer those
um
from kritika do we have model accuracy
monitor feature available in inference
endpoints maybe supporting uh ml that
address
is that something for me or yeah I'm
sort of like picking the questions in
line okay yeah so so what you have seen
on like the analytics tab is basically
in a UI for Prometheus so each endpoint
has available Prometheus
um yeah route you can query and I'm not
super familiar what data bricks has
integrated or like how you can integrate
your analytics into databricks but
that's a way to like integrate the
analytics into your model monitoring
system or if ml floor or something has
some kind of a specific python
integration you might want to add that's
of course doable through a custom
Handler and in there you can like make
the calls for your model trip or like
saving the data and to your backend
awesome I think that Alma asked a few
times already is it possible to use grpc
that's a good question so so currently
the the default container we have used
is
um only supporting HTTP to make it way
easier for everyone to get started and
integrate but custom container should
work with gltc and we haven't tested it
yet maybe you should give it a try but
like there are no like technical
limitations which wouldn't allow grpc to
not work
then we have Tristan asking about uh can
I deploy bloom
um yes or I would say it depends
um you can deploy Bloom but for this you
would need
um the biggest instance which is the and
yeah instance with
um 8 a 100 gpus and for this we might
need to work with you together since all
of us know there's like some kind of GPU
short touch going on but yes you can
like definitely
um deploy blue on inference endpoints
with the correct instance setup
yeah Christian uh Bloom is the largest
multilingual open source model uh that
was released by big science 126 billion
parameters uh just recently and I we
need to uh address stranger questions
because uh they asked it uh many many
times hey Will the source code behind
this be available on GitHub
um so when you're deploying an endpoints
you're pulling
um a repository from the hiking phase
Hub a model so we have a bunch of
examples uh in the inference endpoints
documentation that are open source and
you can see how uh all these recipes to
create a specific endpoints the code of
inference endpoints the solution like
how the auto scaling works and all that
that's uh that will not be released as
open source
um
um oh how do you decide between
horizontal and vertical versus vertical
scaling on our end
from abhinav
don't take that bit
yeah that's a good question
um so the good thing is that
um billing wise it doesn't make any
difference since an instance with one
CPU costs half as much as an instance
with two CPU meaning if you vertically
scale your instance with one CPU to two
CPU you are basically doubling the cost
but if you run two one CPU replicas it's
also double the cost so from from a
pricing perspective it's the same and
then from
um like in this perspective of what you
should do I think it really depends on
your use case so more the more CPUs you
have the the more power I guess your
your mobile has meaning you can like go
faster with latency but if you have more
replica you could handle more requests
in parallel meaning you could have a
higher throughput it really depends on
on your use case and what you would like
to do
the way I was asking that the number of
inference requests matter for pricing
orders upstand uptime is really up time
meaning it's really the the uh the
compute infrastructure uh that your
endpoint is currently using so what the
the parameters are which instance type
you've selected and then uh how the
scaling is uh dynamically uh evolving
um and then
sorry I lost it
yeah maybe I can pick one there's was a
question from badara do you have a plan
to support async predictions which could
handle long prediction more than one or
two three seconds so that the good part
is you are not sharing resources meaning
you when you create an endpoint it's
really your endpoint and if you have
requests which takes 10 or 15 seconds
for like a long generation that's okay
like nobody will break the connection
except the client like closest on a
connection meaning you can run already
like longer prediction and if you send
more load to your endpoint it will
automatically scale up and then like
scale down again so Dale's like no plan
for like those kind of async predictions
since if like one prediction is not
taking longer than like let's say a
minute it should be already kind of
doable
and uh also on the uh on the other
scaling part Victor had a great question
our API calls queued in some way under
the hood prior to other scaling
no
so it's really like it's it's less magic
than you might think of so it's really
like having the same replica split up
and then having a round drop-in concept
from for the load balancer to like split
the load basically on on the end points
so nothing special no cues no
prioritization but of course what you
can do with like a custom Handler you
can like use the python qsdk to like get
in the request and then like offload
them to a separate process and then like
have your in yourself queuing system
um that's definitely possible
from uh Leonardo uh how long does it
take to deploy a mid-sized model like
Bert large say three to five minutes
that what you already see yeah three to
five minutes uh strange yes we have a
Discord server you should join it our
community is there it's amazing
um
there may be a question for you for you
some some kind of asked how does the
customer support for the service work
ah great question uh So within uh infant
endpoints uh you will find a direct uh
link to uh to send uh support questions
to request additional quota uh for uh
for your organization uh thanks for
posting the Discord
um and uh yeah we will we'll create a
nice Community Forum category as well
for uh questions that are an interest to
everybody in the community
uh will Azure hiking face endpoints be
deprecated the service that's now
available in Azure Marketplace no not at
all because uh with Azure ml endpoints
uh you're able to create endpoints
within your own uh Azure tenancy so it's
a really really cool benefit and we're
working with tons of customers to enable
them to do that
um so as as I said at the beginning I
can face inference endpoints is a fully
managed solution where you don't have to
worry about uh all of the underlying
infrastructure we manage it for you in
hacking faces Cloud tenancies
um
yeah yes
answer that means for that
do inference endpoints have any sort of
versioning system from Felipe
um so first the
model system of the hiking face Hub has
a versioning system right you can use
the same sort of Version Control you
would
um with uh with the git project and so
each commit has a revision ID and you
can use that revision ID when you're
creating or an updating uh when you're
creating an endpoint so that means that
you can control exactly
um what's going to drive predictions
what's in underneath your endpoint as
you continue developing your model and
your model evolves and you can easily
switch from one version of your model to
a different version of your model by
creating a new endpoint is there any uh
other part of that question that didn't
answer for that
nope and then maybe for Amy's question
is is it possible to chain models
between several endpoints yes I I
wouldn't suggest it so like each
endpoint has a URL which you can like
send requests to and since you can
create a custom Handler you could like
send a request once your request comes
in but um that that shouldn't be like
something you should do because then you
have like a blocking requests and you
should either rather like integrate more
models into one endpoint or then have
like some kind of like third party
client which sends the request to the
endpoints and like make sure that the
endpoints are not blocking each other
and then I saw maybe like one last
question from Clem and can you give us
one minutes overview of the other
hugging face commercial offering
yes of course uh today thanks Glenn for
the question great question
um today uh we offer
um the private Hub
um so there are over a hundred thousands
of researchers data scientists machine
learning Engineers that come to the
hiking face Hub every day to access and
work with models and all these great
experience we can deliver to a
particular team or company that is
deployed specifically for them so that
they can collaborate and build machine
learning together faster so that's the
private Hub and then the expert
acceleration program that's the most
immediate way we can have impact uh uh
through this service with customers by
having a machine learning engineer at
hiding face provide dedicated direct
support to guide answer questions uh
from customers as they build with uh
with hiking face
um and thanks for thanks for posting uh
posting the links
um maybe okay one last one morteza can I
install custom packages in the container
using the requirements that text uh so
yes so that's what the custom pipeline
uh feature with the Handler Handler uh
that uh by file uh exactly does
um and if you want to bring your own uh
container image you can do that as well
all right
what are we missing
what we're missing is uh for you guys to
uh to go and uh and uh try it out
um uh so yeah I hope I hope you had fun
with it and you build amazing things
yeah Philip
yeah I just wanted to ask Alex question
um there's currently like no budgets so
it's really based on what you use so if
you like to start an end point now you
can like let's say you want to test it
for a day to see if it's working for you
and then you stop it it's really like
for this this one day but um if you're
like interested in some budgets maybe
you like feel free to contact us and
maybe we can work something out which
would fit for you
the recording will be available I will
send you an email after this so that you
can access it thank you so much for
tuning in uh we're super excited can't
wait to see what you guys built with
hiking face inference endpoints all
right team hugging face
signing off